the judge in the case of Donald Trump's
eligibility in 2024 happening in
Colorado turns out to be a donor to the
Democrat uh to Democrats and not just to
Democrats now I love this I think it was
PBS there was a news outlet that said
that there was concern because she had
donated to Liberal groups she donated to
a pack that's specifically trying to
remove Republicans who supported Trump
on January 6th and now she is overseeing
a case where because of January 6
Democrats are arguing Trump is not
eligible to be president so if you
thought this one was going to be fair
surprise surprise now we're hearing that
Minnesota and Michigan are going to have
simal uh similar challenges so that will
be particularly interesting we'll talk
about that plus um oh man you know
normally at this this this stage of the
game I don't really care too much talk
about Ronda sandis but he did he did
disappear on the Patrick Bet uh bet
David value tainment podcast where he
was called out for wearing high heels we
got to we got to talk about this story
cuz this one's oh man I think he's
wearing high heels I really do